I have this writing joke going with my
friend Keith about what it takes to be
an influencer and asked me to get him
the right ingredient but he only got 20
likes so this week we didn't take it to
the next level hi my name is Keith and
it's time to make this flamingo fly it
was at this moment he knew he [ __ ] up
hey brew my name is Dan Mason this is a
video about how to hack your editing and
how to told me the stories if you don't
need it to a storyteller it doesn't
matter because this videos are so about
life well because it's all connected
seamlessly enjoy and that's how not to
editor fold oh definitely for me how I
don't editor phone I used to gravitate
towards edits that were really explosive
fosston just crazy until I realized the
most important part of filmmaking if
it's real YouTube is for making a film
if its premiere whatever it may be is to
treat it like a conversation think of it
like a cadence in a voice to remain
interesting and engaging yet seamless if
that rapid-fire montage with me getting
to my office was a conversation it would
sound something like this driving to the
oven it's cool I like it I think I'm
really cool video which Stephanie is not
seamless and I don't know if you would
ever want to engage in a conversation
with somebody that spoke like that in
saying one of that you definitely need
fast cuts and pace but it's all about
rhythm
rhythmic okay human beings intrinsically
gravitate towards
singing with rhythm like moving your
head to a beat so instead of making a
minute that goes
[Music]
you'd rather want to do something that's
we didn't boot you know I believe that
foam is music for your eyes and
therefore your edit needs to be
seamlessly connected to your narrative
and this all comes down to your writing
and the story that you essentially want
to talk but this tutorial isn't a
writing sterile if you would like
something like that please let me know
in the comments I've already gone out
and captured all my footage shot for
shot as I always ride a shot list the
next thing to do is to record a
voiceover and create this compelling
narrative I record all my videos on a
simple on-board camera mic I then lay
everything down shot for shot like this
beginning to end see then I need a build
a feeling music and sound are crucial in
the creation of any form of emotions
music from all kinds of artists that
have given me the permission to use it
for free on my youtube channel just to
give you some context I use between nine
and thirteen soundtracks
per video if you think about these nine
to thirteen different songs being one
song one song that needs to tell a story
in a motion of climbing then releasing
these climb release climb climb climb
climb climb tour boom we had a climax
that's what I call a narrative arc now
that have my narrative locked in place
I'm going to increase the sensation of
being told the story by adding context
to the chapters through the use of
b-roll but for me most importantly what
I call motion scrapbooking this is a
super rad technique for visually
creating situations I don't have footage
of it has this real nostalgic feeling
attached to it and now I'm passing it
over to you it's time for me to come up
with something new and challenge myself
with a different kind of technique which
I'm su BAM to start working on in order
to achieve the motion scrapbooking
effect you'll need the following a
stable rig this one was recently built
but I've also made use of really
the more unreliable rigs that that still
seemed to do the job scissors scrap
objects of all cons a printer and a
pretty inventive mind basically you need
to one work out how long each merchants
scrapbook section is and where that
action needs to take place this will
give you a good idea of the order you
should animate each subject or object
and how much time between each scene you
have to creating your C otherwise known
as your mission sense using cutouts of
characters environments and objects that
link to the events in your story this we
should really get creative with all
kinds of shapes textures and colors
three shoot frame by frame each time
moving your character slightly to create
movement and bring life to your
characters make sure your lighting is
consistent and there is minimal to no
ambient light as this will be noticeable
in the final piece for take all your
photos and drop them into your project I
use Premiere Pro make sure that your
project sequence is set to 24 frames per
second and that each photo holds for two
frames motion scrapbooking should
generally be shot for 10 to 13 frames
per second to give it that a nostalgic
scrapbooking feel and then fired
compiler together and play it back to
see if it makes sense and if
you're gonna have to go back and do it
again but that is but that's what this
process is
I believe that flaws make it more honest
so definitely don't try and perfect it
and now to integrate this along with ero
and talking headshots into your
narrative in a seamless way the object
here is to create a rhythmic in it and
the best thing about rhythm is its
endless its imaginative youyou don't
have to stick to a specific BPM you just
need a feeling it's kind of like a sixth
sense
an important note a lot of editors and
filmmakers nowadays like to show off
their skill as an editor kind of do that
with the craziest styles sort of
over-the-top moves that's cool and all
but it serves no purpose in a story
other than showing off your skill set
it's kind of like a football player they
can do all the moves to learn on the
side of the field but never really plays
the game and scores with compelling
filmmaking the story will always be
first the way I look at it Vanessa figs
the beta ideally your viewers shouldn't
notice the edit the Edit should be so
good the viewer is rather immersed in
your narrative I do this by sticking to
three quick rules starting with impact
then moving into communication and
ending off with persuasion thank you so
much for watching a tutorial I'm
currently doing something really similar
on Instagram where I'm speaking to other
creatives like Casey nice that almost
yes Theory unlive video interview that I
call the not normal show I'll link it
below or my usernames also Dan mace with
two ends go follow me there now it's
time for a jingle
[Music]
son that was cool right you can learn
that on Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
that you subscribe to you signed up for
a bunch of dope causes the first time I
gave away premium membership packages
and the top three were learning how to
edit on Adobe Premiere Pro for beginners
to the fundamentals of DSLR photography
and three managing attention in the
digital age which is also one of my
favorites but if you missed the last one
don't worry we are giving away two
hundred more premium memberships for
free in the link below and if you learn
something cool and share it
tag me on it I'm keen to see thank you
so much for watching don't forget your
awesome
[Music]
you
[Music]